snow falls gently on the city it keeps
us inside with our families at blankets
our sins and then it turns into a giant
puddle of slush in New York the
Department of Transportation decides
where to put storm drains but when it
snows people shovel out to the curb
plows push in to the curb and this
creates a snow dam in winter the snow
decides whether water can get to the
drain often it decides no but it's not
the snows fault blames civil engineering
the center of every road the crown is
higher than the curb in New York City
for example the streets are paved on a
1.5 to 4.2 percent grade from crown to
curb this helps water runoff the roadway
but when that water meets a snow dam it
stays at the curb what's good for cars
is bad for pedestrians and in New York
City curbs run between 7 and 10 inches
high that is about the height of a
classic l.l.bean boot if that is not
what you're wearing you have to jump and
the Department of Transportation says
that all corners need at least one ramp
in business districts - this means a
bigger puddle and a bigger jump